so here's what happens in this and and
we put this in just for a moment and it
came out but there's an amazing moment
here this buffalo bull is chasing the
Lions and very often big Bulls do chase
Lions but this is an extraordinary
moment and and I must say near the end
of this we both of us sort of started
laughing in the vehicle because the bull
is completely in charge the Lions are
scattered all over the place and then
watch what happens here so again Lions
panicked this bull completely in charge
runs behind the palm
comes out the other side in deep trouble
and it's amazing how these things can
suddenly turn again I loved the fact
that he just went into the water as an
escape and of course the water slows him
down a lot but in this particular case
the water definitely saved him
you